ne pas se sentir seul pour les fêtes
opération réussie avec le gala de noël
organisée à la résidence orpéa de saint
rémy les chevreuse les seniors se sont
rassemblés autour d'un repas et ont
assisté à un spectacle de cabaret en
trois volets et puis noir des plus
belles et des plus toutes les couleurs
et forcément ça fait ça fait music hall
c'est un spectacle musical on se serait
presque au crazy horse
elles sont pas mal les femmes sont
maintenant un tout petit peu ça manque
d'hommes enfin bref c'était très bien
pour les messieurs c'est un très bon
temps et comme a été très gâté on est
toujours très gâtés du chant de la danse
le temps d'un après-midi les personnes
âgées ont que contre avec la solitude
s'amuse à sortir un peu de ce qu'on
pourrait appeler la routine c'est un
événement dans une maison de retraite la
résidence orpéa de saint rémy les
chevreuse accueille plus de 300
résidents moi ce qui me satisfait c'est
de voir l'émotion des résidents la
satisfaction des résidents leur sourire
quand ils sortent ce spectacle et qui me
disent qu'ils ont passé un super moment
et bien voilà nous sommes ravis et c'est
ce à quoi aujourd'hui
on s'attache énormément
dans notre village le prochain rendez
vous est donné aux résidents un
spectacle aura lieu en ce début d'année
pour célébrer 2019 un magicien sera de
la partie
[Applaudissements]